in 2013 Dark Horse Comics release an
illustrated version of George Lucas's
original 1974 script for a space opera
called the Star Wars the comic books
gave series fans a glimpse of how
Lucas's original vision evolved into
what we saw on the screen some of the
differences are staggering in the Star
Wars Luke Skywalker is introduced not as
an idealistic young farm boy from
Tatooine but rather as a grizzled 60
year old general on the planet actually
one of the few planets not taken over by
the Empire he's a Jedi been due a member
of a group of warriors who were once the
sworn defenders of the Emperor the group
has since defected and its members are
being hunted by the Sith very few Jedi
elect and their numbers are dwindling
just like they are in a new hope the
roles of our heroes shift around a bit
in this first draft which introduces
another Jedi Bendu by the name of Caine
Starkiller Caine lives on a desolate
moon with his two sons deke and Anakin
while he was born a human he's mostly
cyborg by the time we meet him left with
nothing but his original head and arm
after a life of brutal combat after
young deke is killed by a surprise
attack Cain and Anakin flee to acrylate
so that the brush young Anakin can
complete his Jedi Ben do training with
Luke shades of Anakin Skywalker's
attitude from attack of the clones are
apparent here but instead of the Jedi
braid Anakin sports a combination of a
mullet and a man bun it's not any cooler
it's just different the villain known as
Darth Vader is still imposing in these
Star Wars but he's a lot better looking
while he bares some of the scars of the
Vader we know he has one robotic red eye
and a full head of hair in this version
he's a tactical commander of the Empire
he has no special powers he's need the
Jedi nor Seth while he expresses some
respect for Darkseid users of the force
his feelings quickly diminish when they
fail to get him instant results this
Vader occasionally wears the trademark
helmet but only the top part he doesn't
need the rest of his suit after all this
interpretation comes from before Vader
was known to have a burnt-up backstory
but helmet or no helmet
he still looks like he probably sounds
like James Earl Jones
Princess Leia doesn't play the heroic
role here that she assumes in a new hope
instead she's a college student who
needs to be rescued after war breaks out
on aqua late instead of a New Hope's
Luke Skywalker who's a nice sweet boy
she's retrieved by Anakin Starkiller an
unlikable jerk who punches her in the
face when he needs her to cooperate
despite these harsh beginnings the two
eventually fall in love for reasons not
even this script can explain when Leia's
father is killed she becomes the queen
of aqua late and the empire zeroes in on
her as a target turns out her planet
possesses valuable cloning technology to
get control of the planet and it's
lucrative tech the Empire sets out to
capture her and her siblings like a lot
of material from this early script the
name valorum eventually showed up in the
movies just in a different way in these
Star Wars prints valorum is a powerful
Sith who's called in by the Empire for
his Jedi hunting expertise he's hired to
capture the heroes and though he never
quite succeeds his mask makes him look
pretty badass even when he's failing the
Darth Vader we got in a new hope is
basically a combination of these Star
Wars is Veda and valorum originally
neither of those guys were that
effective as a villain mix the two
together though and the result is iconic
the r2d2 we know only speaks and beeps
and bloops but in these Star Wars he
speaks in full sentences all while still
looking like a walking talking trash can
unlike his astromech droid friend
c-3po didn't change much from his first
appearances in the Star Wars in a way
that frustrating snooty protocol droid
is one of this sprawling franchise's
biggest constants and for that we salute
him I do believe they think I am some
sort of God one of the most dramatic
changes from V Star Wars to Star Wars
proper is the appearance of Han Solo's
character while his original version was
still a morally ambiguous scoundrel he
was also an enormous green guild
creature as opposed to a dashing young
Harrison Ford an extra complication is
that his particular species was a
generally known for killing walkies not
to befriending them making his eventual
partnership with Chewbacca all but
impossible in these early drafts even
under his scaly skin though solo seems
like pretty much the same guy in these
Star Wars wikis basically served the
same purpose that the Ewoks do in Return
of the Jedi they're still 8 foot tall
killing machines but they're also very
superstitious like the Ewoks they also
live in a society that looks a lot like
the Ewoks village in the original story
Anakin Starkiller beats the Wookiee
chief in combat and is subsequently
worshipped a development that's
ultimately played for laughs in the
movies by c-3po instead it's not too far
off from the Wookiee society we
eventually learn about in Revenge of the
Sith and of course the Star Wars Holiday
Special
maybe it would have been cooler if
Return of the Jedi took place on
Chewbacca's turf following an army of
wookies instead of an Ewok insurrection
by the end of the script for the Star
Wars Sith Prince valorum and Jedi Ben do
Anakin Starkiller actually team up to
deal a blow to the empire after valorum
decides Vader is too disloyal to work
with interestingly valorum has a lots of
criticism for Anakin over his love for
Princess Leia
according to valorum emotions are a
peculiar weakness of the Jedi been due
with such raw feelings supposedly being
unbecoming of a Sith as the prequels
eventually established it's supposed to
be the Jedi who advocate shunning one's
emotions while the Sith embrace their
feelings to become more powerful
ultimately after the Jedi teach the
Wookiees how to fly spaceships the Death
Star fortress is destroyed
taking Vader with it aqua lay is saved
along with princess leia and her royal
family anakin Starkiller is given the
job of being the chief protector of the
planet and the rest of the galaxy is at
peace with the Star Wars in a cease fire
at least for now overall these Star Wars
makes for a decent familiar story which
is nonetheless too complicated for
better and for worse many of the ideas
in Lucas's original script were saved
and dispersed throughout the Star Wars
we know today can you really
this guy as a wookie eating
scruffy-looking swamp monster who's
scruffy-looking